[موسيقى]
مساله السودان
يجب ان احنا نتفهم
يعني ايه وجود دوله
لها مؤسسات لها حكومه لها رئاسه لها
سلطتها
وما بين هذه المؤسسات هي قوات مسلحه
القوه المسلحه
الرسميه للدوله لا يتصور انه يكون فيه لها
شريك او خصم او طرف اخر من القوه المسلحه
مسلح فدائما مثل هذا النوع من التواجد
احدهما يتغلب على الاخر
السياق العام اللي احنا كنا متابعينه
وبنتابعوا انه كان في اطار
يتم التفاوض عليه انه
قوه التدخل السريع هتخش جوه الجيش صحيح
واختلفوا على او اختلفوا شكلا على الفتره
هيحتاجها هذا الاندماج لكن عندما تبين
الاطراف انه لا يمكن ما يحصلش بشكل
بايقاع عالي كان الصدام حتمي
[موسيقى]
خلف ولا رئيس برهان ولا الفريق اول حماتي
ولكن الجامعه العربيه
في قراراتها الاخيره منذ بدء الازمه هي
بدات بطلب وقفه اطلاق نار
ثم بدا الموقف يتطور في سياق تطوره في
قرار امام القمه اقر من مجلس وزراء
الخارجيه اليوم
اقر من مجلس وزراء الخارجيه الاسبوع
الماضي في
القاهره ومن اجتماعات المندوبين بتتحدث عن
المؤسسات الرسميه
وضروره الحفاظ على المؤسسات الرسميه
في سياق هذه المؤسسات الرسميه للقوات
المسلحه طبعا
لكن
لا نستطيع نحن نقول انه الجامعه بتتبنى
موقف هذا الطرف او ذاك هي بتطلب وقف اطلاق
نار وانهاء هذا الوضع باسرع وقت ممكن